شكرا لك صهيب اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نتابع واياكم في هذه التغطيه المتواصله من
العربيه لتطورات الاحداث في السودان اخر
نتائج الفوضى هناك هروب عمر البشير من سجن
كوبر تسريب هذا الخبر جاء من داخل نظام
البشير وبالتحديد من احد قياداته احمد
هارون المسؤول في نظام البشير الذي اكد
انه غادر سجن كوبر مع اخرين من قيادات
نظام البشير وانهم سيؤمنون الحمايه
لانفسهم بعد وصولهم الى جهه امنه هارون
اكد انه والبشير وقيادات النظام المعزول
انهم جاهزون للمثول امام القضاء في اي وقت
[موسيقى]
نستمع الى التسجيل الصوتي لاحقا في سياق
هذه الساعه تسجيل صوتي لاحمد هارون
المطلوب للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في
قضايا جنائيه تتعلق بعمليات النظام السابق
في دارفور مصادر العربيه تحدثت عن ان عوض
الجاز وابراهيم السنوسي ايضا ضمن قيادات
نظام البشير التي غادرت سجن كوبر ونافع
عالي نافع وعلي عثمان طه ايضا من ضمن هذه
القيادات التي غادرت السجن هناك ردود فعل
من القوه المدنيه ولكن بعد ان نشير الى ان
الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
ونائبه بكري حسن صالح في المستشفى العسكري
بالخرطوم وفقا لمصادر العربيه سنحاول
التاكد من كل هذه المعلومات اولا باول وما
يستجد منها في اول رد من القوى المدنيه
على اعلان القيادي احمد هارون في نظام
الرئيس السابق خروجهم من السجن قال
القيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير ياسر
عرمان ان بي البشير بعد مغادرتهم السجن
دعوه لتوسيع نطاق الحرب
سنحاول اذا ان نستمع الى الصوت في هذا
التسجيل بعد قليل ياسر عرمان قال ان بيان
قيادات نظام البشير بعد مغادرتهم السجن
يتعارض مع ما يريده السودانيون ويقول ايضا
هذا البيان بعد مغادرتهم السجن دعوه
لتوسيع نطاق الحرب كما ذكرنا
يعني هناك التوقعات بالمزيد من المواقف
فيما يتعلق بهذا التطور الكبير ضمن تطورات
الاحداث في السودان طبعا يمكن ان نشير الى
بعض الاخبار التي كان من المفترض ان استمع
اليها في هذا التسجيل عن يعني احمد هارون
المسؤول السابق في نظام البشير حول
مغادرته سجن كوبر يقول مكثنا في سجن كوبر
تحت حراسه محدوده اداره سج اجلت القيادات
المعتقله تحت حراسه محدوده وجاهزونا
للمطول امام القضاء في اي وقت هؤلاء
القيادات غادروا السجن وسيؤمنون الحمايه
لانفسهم ويقول انه غادر مع اخرين اذا معنا
الان من اندرمان الصحفيه فاطمه ابراهيم
اهلا بك معنا فاطمه كيف هو الوضع الان في
ام درمان تحديدا
تحيه لك طاهر وتحيه لكل متابعي قناه الحدث
نعم الان هناك اصوات رصاص اضافه الى اصوات
الغذائف
الاندرمان وان القصص ايضا رغم الهدنه التي
تم اعلانها ولكن
ظهر اليوم تم القصف على مركز الرومي الطبي
بن درمان الحاره 12 تسبب في اصابه عشره
اشخاص تم نقلهم الى مستشفى النوم احد
المستشفيات القريبه من المركز لتلقي
العلاج الجدير بالذكر طاهر انه هذا المركز
قبل يعني دقائق من افتتاحه او ساعات من
افتتاحه تم نشر يعني بيان على صفحته على
فيسبوك
بمزاوله العمل ودعا جميع الاطباء القريبين
من على المركز للحضور لتقديم الخدمات
العلاجيه
للمرضى ولكن للاسف يعني تم قصفه مع بدايه
العمل هذا المركز يعتبر سنتر بالنسبه
للسكان اندرمان خاصه الثورات لانه يقدم
خدماتها علاجيه وبه عدد من يعني العيادات
وفي جميع التخصصاتها وعدد كبير جدا من
التخصصات وعدد من الاستشاريين ايضا داخل
المركز اضافه الى صيدليه كبيره تمد المركز
وكل المرضى بالعقاقير الطبيه للاشف تم من
جديد اغلاق هذا المركز فبالتالي ما
البدائل الموجوده الان امام السودانيين في
تلك المنطقه فاطمه
للاسف للاسف فهناك يعني مستشفى مستشفى
النو هي برضو كانت مغلقه تماما تم استئناف
العمل فيها بمجهودات يعني
مجهودات الاهالي ولكن للاسف يعني تعمل
بامكانيات محدوده فهي تستقبل فقط الحالات
الخفيفه ولكن هناك عدد من الحالات الصعبه
والمستحصيه وكان من الاصابات او من
الامراض
المزمنه ولكن يعني عندما تم قصف هذا
المركز اغلقت جميع الابواب امام وجوهها
المرضى وهم كما تعلمون لا يستطيعون التجول
في العاصمه الخرطوم او سواء كان في
اندرمان او بحري او حتى الخرطوم نسبه يعني
الوضع الامني الخطير جدا الذي يهدد حياه
المواطنين فاطمه هل هناك ايه معلومات
ايه حتى لو نقلت لنا نبض شارع والناس
بخصوص المعلومات الاخيره ان لم يكن هناك
معلومات رسميه او حزبيه بخصوص الم علومات
الاخيره عن يعني انتقال قيادات نظام
البشير الى جهه غير معلومه بعد وجودهم في
السجن
نعم هناك حديث نعم وسط يعني المواطنين
يتحدثون عن يعني
متفاجئون تماما عن خروج قيادات النظام
البائد خارج السجن خاصه يعني صرح
المحامي الرئيس البشير المخلوع عفوا بانه
الان الرئيس المخلوع عمر البشير يعني
يتلقى العلاج بمستشفى السلاح الطبي ولكن
عدد ايضا من قيادات النظام البائد عوض
الجاهز ونافعه لناسيا واحمد هارون التي
الذي يعني تم تسجيل الصوت له وهو متداول
الان عبر الوسائط و عبر القنوات ايضا فهم
الان يعني على سن للاسف المواطنون يعتبرون
هذا الخروج لهم هو ايضا انقلاب مباشر
ومخطط له للاسف هذا ما يدور في الاوساط
السودانيه فيعتبرون هذا هو انقلاب ومخطط
له فبالتالي هي هذا الخروج بالنسبه يعني
قيادات النظام البائد الى الواجهه من جديد
يعتبرون هذا سيكون في في الايام المقبله
هم الذين يقودون يعني الحركه السياسيه
بطريقه او
بالواجهه مباشره او حتى خلف الكواليس نقاط
مهمه جدا جديره بالمتابعه مع ضيوفنا شكرا
جزيلا لك يا استاذه فاطمه ابراهيم الصحفيه
من ام درمان الان الى القاهره مع دكتور
محمد زيات مستشار المركز المصري للفكر
ودراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك دكتور
تعتبره تطور كبير اليس كذلك
نعم هو تطور كبير ودخول
عامل جديد في المعادله التي تحكم الصراع
الجاري في السودان على مدى الايام الماضيه
الطرف الثالث والذي دخل الان وترى من
ساعده على الخروج وهل سيكون قوه سادسه في
الميدان يعني اذا كان التركيز يتم على
محاوله التوفيق بين طرفي الصراع فنحن امام
طرف ثالث دخل الى الحلبه والى الميدان
الطرف الثالث ربما كانت القيادات لكن
بالتاكيد لقوا خلايا موجوده وله عن انصار
موجودين ربما كانت تختفي واليوم السلاح
مفتوح في السودان على على اتساعه وربما
نرى تحركات ثالثه هو اول تصريح لارون كان
الشيء الملفت فيه انه اتهمى قاده الانقلاب
يعني مجلس السياده والجيش بهذا الامر
وبالتالي فانك استعداد لان يكون طرفا في
العمليه السياسيه التي تجري وربما وجد ان
المناخ يسمح له بالعوده سنراقب الايام
القادمه ونرى اذا ما كان سينخرط في الصراع
العسكري القادم او سوف يحاول ان يكون طرفا
في التسويه السياسيه التي تتم هل تعتقد
دكتور من خلال قراءتك بانه هذا قد يكون
يعني من الجيد ان يتم اشراك هؤلاء بغض
النظر عن المدامين عن المتهمين او
المدانين منهم قد يكون من الجيب بالمعنى
السياسي اشراك هذا الفريق هذا التوجه
بمعنى انه كان جزء من المشكله
يعني هو جزء من المشكله طبعا لكن اعتقد
انه هذا
الجناح او هذا الفصيل او هذا المكون مرفوض
من كافه القوى السياسيه الموجوده في
السودان ولا اعتقد ان الامر الان يتم البت
فيه عودتهم قبل انتهاء محاكماتهم وانتهاء
السجن المقرب بالنسبه لهم ام لا لكن هي
القضيه الان في السودان ليست القفز على
الواقع الحالي الواقع الحالي للمرير هو
الصراع العسكري والاهداف الاستراتيجيه
التي لها الاولويه هي كيفيه استمرار
الهدنه وكيفيه يعني اعطاء المواجهه
تداعيات المعركه العسكريه التي جرت على
المواطنين وعلى الشعب يعني البنيه
الاساسيه فيما يتعلق
بالمستشفيات والقوه اليوم للمواطن غير
موجود
الاجلاء الذي تم من جانب القوى الكبرى
والدول الاخرى لراعيها تركت الساحه مفتوحه
ربما لو لم يتم الاجلاء لكان هناك عمليه
ضبط للعمليات العسكريه في المدن
من اخلاء المدن من الاجانب ربما خففت
حرص القوه الدوليه على وقف المواجهات هل
تستمر الهدنه التي تم فرضها لمده ثلاثه
ايام ان يستمر الخرق هناك انتشار لقوات
الرد السريع داخل المدن وهل يمكن ان تقبل
على اي اساس سيتم باستمرار الهدنه او
تثبيتها بدون معايير كيف يتم التثبيت ومن
يفرض على اطراف الاخرى التثبيت الميدان
العملياتي على مستوى السودان يختلف في
الخرطوم عنه في الولايات الاخرى اليوم
لاحظنا ان هناك بدايه لحراك فيه في
كردفان وفي الاوبيض فهل نحن امام انتشار
في مواقع اخرى لم تشهد حسبا كما يجري في
الخرطوم الامر مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات
دكتور محمد هناك يعني سؤال ايضا بخصوص
حاله الفوضى الان في السودان بعد هروب عدد
كبير من
السجناء والمتهمين هذا قد يعني يشي
بامكانيه او ينذر بخطوره انتقال جماعات
متطرفه او متشدده وتكوين قاعده جديده بيئه
خصبه لها في السودان الى اي مدى باعتقادك
هذا واقعي ان نتصوره ويشكل
مثار قلق عند القاهره ودول الجوار
هذا هذا الاحتمال او هذا السيناريو مطروح
منذ بدايه العمليات العسكريه وعندما يعود
قيادات كانت تمثل رموزا لتيار الاسلام
السياسي الذي كان موجود هناك وكانت راعيه
منذ البدايه اغلقيادات تنظيم القاعده التي
استوطنت في السودان قبل الذهاب الى
افغانستان
وبالنظر الى ان هناك
تمركز لقوات القاعده وداعش يعتبر التمركز
الرئيسي لها خارج خارج افغانستان وخارج
خارج اسيا في منطقه الساحل والصحراء وما
يجري في بوركينا فاسو وفي مالي وفي جنوب
ليبيا وامتداد المنطقه بصوره قريبه ومن
تشاد هذه الامور كلها تنذر بان المجال فتح
على هذه التنظيمات للعوده الى الى السودان
اسمح لي دكتور مجاهد اعود لك بعد قليل
اعود اليك بعد قليل لو تكرمت معنا من
الخرطوم الان يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بك استاذ
يوسف على شاشه العربيه
كيف كيف تتناول او تقرا معنا الاخبار
نتحدث به احمد هارون في التسجيل الصوتي
والاخبار عن اماكن تواجد قيادات كبرى من
النظام السابق
نعم نحن نتوقع منذ اليوم الاول لانقلاب
الحركه الاسلاميه الذي يدبره على الكرتي
نتوقع كل هذا كان لو نجح الانقلاب ولو لم
تفشله قوات الدعم السريع لتم اطلاقهم علنا
لاستضافتهم القنوات اللي كان الشعب
السوداني الذي لقبه ديسمبر الان ضحيه
لعودتهم الى السلطان لكن هذا امر متوقع
ومستفز للشعب السوداني
مجلس السياده وقوات الجيش باطلاق سراح
قيادات النظام السابق اذا
العناصر الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا لا اتهم
كل الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه اسلاميه
هنالك ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهات داخل
الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك جهاز ضباط
اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراح هذه
المجموعه نحن لدينا معلومات من داخل السجن
لحظه اطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام السجن لحظه
اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا لم تكن
قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه تعرف انه الاتهام
المضاد هو لكم انتم باقتحام السجون
وبالتحرير هؤلاء
يا اخي نحن ليس لدينا مصلحه نحن منذ اليوم
الاول اطلقنا راينا واضح انما نواجه هو
انقلاب بتخطيط من الحركه الاسلاميه وقد
عبرنا عن ذلك منذ اليوم الاول انهم هذه
المساله هذه التجربه حدثت في سجن الهدى
وقد رحب بها المؤتمر الوطني في صفحته وعبر
عنها عدد من رموز المؤتمر الوطني وابواقي
في السوشيال ميديا محتفلين بهذا وكانوا
يدبرون معهد للعمليه الثانيه ما هي مصلحه
الدعم السريع في اطلاق عناصر النظام
البيئي ما هي مصلحته في ذلك وهو يقاتل
انقلاب اصلا دبرته الحركه الاسلاميه هذا
هذا حديث يطلقونه هم
للتشويش لتغبيش الوعي بتاع الناس لكن
الشعب السوداني واعي والعالم واعي وقد عبر
احمد هارون بصراحه عن دعمه للجيش الجيش
الذي يقصده جيش الحركه الاسلاميه وعناصر
الحركه الاسلاميه لم يذكر البرهان بل وصف
ما حدث من اعتياز للقوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع لثوره ديسمبر بالانقلاب
بمعنى انه حتى برهان الذي كان جزءا رئيس
مجلس اول مجلس السياده في في ذو الحكومه
الثوره انه انقلاب
مجرد الجيش من الشرف انه الحازمي ثوره
ديسمبر انت تقول انا جيش منقسم على نفسه
انت تقول انه جيش منقسم على نفسه والبرهان
لا يمثل كله وان البرهان جزء من هذا من
هذه الحركه الاسلاميه الانقلابيه
نعم البرهان تامر مع الحركه الاسلاميه
البهان تامر مع علي كرسي الحركه الاسلاميه
نفسها كلها ليست موحده الحركه الاسلاميه
لما نتكلم عن الحركه الاسلاميه اتكلم عن
الحركه الاسلاميه يقودها الامين العام علي
كرتي واسامه عبد الله ومن معه من من من
هنالك اسلاميين ليس ليسوا طرفا في هذا
هنالك اسلاميين عبروا بصوت واضح انهم
ليسوا طرفا في انقلاب ولا يدعمون العنف
ولا يدعمون عوده النظام نظامهم الا عبر
الانتخابات هذا حديث عبرت عنه وقيادات قبل
من قبل كان يصر على العوده واعلن ذلك
صراحه قال لن ننتظر بعد هذا في رمضان هل
لديكم معلومات هل لديكم معلومات عن اماكن
تواجد قيادات النظام السابق وعلى راسهم
عمر البشير وبكري حسن صالح وعبد الرحيم
محمد حسين حتى الان لا تتواج لا تتوفر
لدينا معلومات يمكن الاستناد عليها ولكن
كل الاستخبارات الدعم السريع وكل كل قواته
مجلد للبحث عن هؤلاء والقبض عليهم لان
هؤلاء فيهم مطلوبين للمحكمه الجنائيه
مجرمين بصفتكم من تريدون القبض عليهم
اريد القبض على هذه المجموعه الهاربه من
السجن هل انتم قوات دعم سريع بصفتكم ماذا
تريدون القبض عليهم هناك جيش وهناك مجلس
سياده صح
يا عزيزي الان نحن نسيطر على كافه مداخل
ومخارج مدينه الخرطوم نسيطر على بحري
نسيطر على درمان نسيطر على الكباري نسيطر
على كل شيء لدينا مسؤوليه جهه شعبنا
السوداني لدينا مسؤوليه تجاه
الثوره السودانيه هؤلاء مجرمين
رفضهم الشعب السوداني علنا هؤلاء لديهم
جرائم ارتكبوا جرائم في دارفور مطلوبين
فيها للعداله بها ايضا انتم كنتم جزء من
هذا انتم جزء اساسي مما حصل في دارفور ولو
ليس هناك مذكرات دوليه بحقكم شخصيا او بحق
بعض القيادات الاخرى
يا عزيزي يختلف ان تقاتل حركات مسلحه تحمل
السلاح
او ان تقوم بحرق القرى نحن لسنا متهمين
قياده الدعم السريع ليست متهمه ولا في اي
مكان عبر حتى النازعين حتى كل الحركات
المسلحه لم تتهم قياده
ماذا يقول كل المحللين سياسيين الذين
يظهرون معنا ولا تاخذ الكلام عني ولكن
عنهم يقولون قوات الدعم السريع بدات هي
الجنجويد في الاساس وهي عماد النظام
السابق والرئيس البشير في كل ما حصل في
دارفور وان النظام السابق هو الذي كونها
وانشاها والان انتم تقولون انه نحن لسنا
حركه اسلاميه والى ما هنالك كيف هذا
التناقض
يا اخي يا اخي دعني اقول لك شيء انت تعلم
ان الجفا الاسلامي او النظام الاسلامي قسم
المجتمع في دارفور الى عرب الى زرقه
الحركات المسلحه تكونت من مجموعات اسميه
محدده هنالك حرب قبليه طاحنه شجعها النظام
هنالك استقطاب هنالك لجوء
للحمل السلاح للدفاع عن النفس هنالك معارك
كثيره هذه مساله معدده يعلمها تعلمها كل
الجهاز هذا هذا الواقع
افرز هو نحن الدعم السريع لم لم يولد قوه
زنجبيل الدعم السريع تاسس سنه 2013 هذا هو
قرار تاسيس التاريخ تاسيس الدعم السريع
نعم اسس القائد العام للجيش البشير القائد
الاعلى للجيش هذا معلوم ولكن هل كان اسسه
كقوه مؤدلجه هل اسسوا كقوه تتبع للحركه
الاسلاميه كما هي الامن الشعبي وارتفاع
الشعبي وغيره كل هذه القوه تتبع للحركه
الاسلاميه ومنظمه لكن الدعم السريع لا
قائده منظم في الحركه الاسلاميه ولم يكن
يوما عضوا في المؤتمر الوطني كان عسكريا
صرفا بالتالي انتم الان ستحاربونهم يعني
اذا كان لهم دور عسكري او سياسي
ستحاربونهم وهم الان خارج السجون
التي دارت فيها الحرب نحن نعرف من نحارب
هم يحاربوننا في الاعلام يحاربوننا على
الميدان كل الذين نحاربهم نحن لا نحارب
الجيش وقد علمنا ذلك الجيش بريء الجيش
حراره مختطف الجيش يتعرض لمؤامره ولدينا
ما يثبت ذلك بلقد قلنا ذلك اليوم الاول
انما نواجهه هو
وعودتهم الى السلطه هذا عبرنا عنه بوضوح
وخروجهم وبيانهم يؤكد ما نحن ذهبنا اليه
طيله هذه الفتره احنا لم نقل ذلك ممنهج
وصحيفه سوداني الان تتحدث عن هروب مئات
النزلاء من سجن نيالا الكبير بولايه جنوب
دارفور ما بعرف اذا عندك معلومات عن هذا
الموضوع يعني في معلومات
ليس لدي اي معلومات اذا كان هذا الامر
ممنهج استاذ يوسف شو بدي اكون تداعياته
وموقفكم بالتالي يعني هل تتصورون بانه
هناك تحضير لما هو اكبر في الايام القادمه
من خلال قياده هؤلاء لعمليه سياسيه جديده
مختلفه كليا عن كل مخرجات ثوره
يا اخي يا اخي هؤلاء لفظهم الشعب السوداني
ولم يقبلهم الشعب السودان ولن يقبلهم سوار
ديسمبر ولن تقبلهم القوه المدنيه السياسيه
ولن يقبلهم العالم لانهم مطلوبين للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ولديهم جرائم معروفه هذه
هذه هذه النظام بايت هذه قيادات استهلكت
هذه قيادات ليس لديها جديد تقدمه حكمت 30
سنه ذاق الشعب الامرين من حكمهم الشعب ليس
في الخرطوم واحده في الخرطوم فتحت السجون
والمعتقلات وتشريد الشعب ذاكر ته اربع
سنوات لحكمهم في دارفور ما زال النازحين
واللاجئين في شركه الشهد في جبال النوبه
ما زال الناس يتذكرون اصوات
النيل الازرق في كبار في في الشهداء يدفون
هذه هذه ذاكره حيه لا يمكن ان يقفز عليها
لا يمكن ان يجدوا سنه شعبي لا يمكن ان
تنحاز لهم اي قوه سياسيه هؤلاء هذه قيادات
لا عشره ايام ونحن نعلم حرقهم ولم ينتصروا
في اي معركه يقول انه الوضع مستقر وانت
تقول انه تسيطرون على مداخل ومخارج
الخرطوم والسودان بلد كبير جدا يعني
والولايات كلها مستقره ليس فيها اخبار عن
اشتباكات او اقتتال وبالتالي انتم ليس
لديكم
اي موطئ قدم فيها
يا اخي نحن حين نقول كلمه يسمعها شعبنا
قناتك الان التي تذيع مفتوحه في كل البيوت
السودانيه لا يمكن ان نكذب على الشعب
السوداني ولا يمكن ان نقود اعلامي
وانتصارات وهميه في في قنوات التلفزيون
نحن نسيطر نحن موجودين في الشارع موجودين
في الاذاعه والتلفزيون موجودين في القسم
موجودين في صياد العامه موجودين في مطار
الخرطوم موجودين في كل الكباري المؤديه
منه الى المدن الثلاث نحن موجودين وي
علم يمرون بنا كل يوم اثناء الهدنه اليوم
مرت الاف الناس عبر الكباري التي تسيطر
عليه وعبر
دبلوماسيه خارجه نحن لا نكذب هذا هذه
مسؤوليه نحن لا نكسب ما الذي يدعونا ان
نكذب وندعي بطولات ليست لنا هذا هذا واقع
موجود وشعبنا يعلم انه موجود
ومن يكذب ذلك
يلعب في الفضائيات وفي الانترنت وكذا لكن
هذا واقع موجود على الارض طيب بس خطتكم
المقال مش موضوع كذب في عوامل الحرب نفسيه
بتلعب دورها الكل بيعرف هذا الموضوع من
العادي جدا بانه يصير من الطرفين ولكن
الان شو خطتكم يعني في هدنه بعد باقي منها
مثلا يومين ماذا ستفعلون
يا اخي هذه الهدنه الهدف منها هدف انسان
هنالك معاناه انسانيه في في المدن ليس في
الخرطوم واحده حتى في المدن الاخرى في
الولايات هنالك معاناه طاحنه هذه المعاناه
الانسانيه تتطلب تعامل جاءت هنالك الجثث
ملقاه في الشوارع في كل الخرطوم تحللت
هنالك قضايا هناك قضايا انسانيه
هنالكهرباء مقطوعه هنالك مياه مقطوعه في
بحري نحن التزمنا بالهدنه الاسلاميه
الهدنه
الانسانيه لصالح شعبنا لصالح مواطنين
ونلتزم بها وسنظل نلتزم بها بعد ذلك لكل
يعني جزء كبير شريحه كبيره من السودانيين
لعلها تقول الان ردا عليك بانه انتم يعني
تشنون الحرب ومن ثم تمنون علينا
بهدنه لثلاثه ايام كي نزلقت لا نعم من
الشوارع
يا اخي هذه الحرب تم اطلاقها يعلم الجميع
من تم اطلاقها من هاجم في الصباح يوم 15
الدعم السريع في مقراتي من اعلن حل الدعم
السريع من اعلن الدعم السريع هو متمرده
ويجب طردها وضربها من اطلق الحرب نحن لم
نطلق الحرب نحن نحن واجهنا الحرب دفاعا عن
النفس هذا الانقلاب رتب له قيادات في
الجيش وقيادات في الحركه الاسلاميه
الهدف الاساسي من القضاء على الدرب بضربه
خاطفه على الدعم السريع وكانوا خطتهم
ان ينت
ه اذا انت عم تتهم البرهان انه جزء من هذا
التحرك ومن الحركه الاسلاميه في الجيش
والى ما هنالك يعني سينقلب على نفسه يعني
لماذا يقول لماذا يقود انقلاب هو رئيس
مجلس السياده هو قائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه
ليس الانقلاب على نفسه الانقلاب على عمليه
سياسيه كامله احنا ظللنا لشهور نعمل في
عمليه سياسيه بموجبه يخرج الجيش من السلطه
يجب تفكيك التمكين تمكين الحركه الاسلاميه
في الجيش بشكل معلن اصلاح الجيش بشكل كامل
اصلاح كل المنظومه الامنيه البرهان نفسه
يجب ان يوقع يوم 1/4 على خروجه من السلطه
خرج في اخر ورشه للاصلاح الامني انسحب تم
سحب الجيش نحن كنا موجودين حتى نهايه
الورشه داخل قاعه الصداقه هذا الانقلاب
على عمليه سياسيه كانت ستؤسس لسلطه مدنيه
كانت
الحاربين بمال الشعب للتمكين كل هذه هذا
ذاكره غريبه قبل شهر كل شيء كان معدل
جاهز نحن وقعنا على ذلك من السلطه البرهان
كانت سلطته
للحركه الاسلاميه او الحركه الاسلاميه
اقنعت بانها ستكون الحاضنه له وينغلب على
الجميع ويسترك الرئيس هذا هذه هذا هو ما
حدث هل انتم مستعدون لتمديد الهدنه
اذا كانت لصالح شعرنا واذا كانت لصالح
المواطنين لا يوجد لا يوجد شيء الان لا
توجد مواجهات حقيقيه بين الجيش على الارض
هل انتم عسكريا وسياسيا مستعدون لتمديد
الهدنه
بعد انتهاء الهدنه اذا التزم بها الطرف
الاخر اذا كانت هنالك سيطره حقيقيه على
الجيش لان اليوم الجيش خرج الهدنه في اكثر
من موقع هنالك طياره ضربت في الصالحه
هنالك هجوم على قواتنا هنالك هجوم واسع
يبدو ان الجيش ليست لديه زياده مركزيه
تسيطر عليه فقيادته تعلن الاربع هدنات
التي تمت يخرجها الجيش علنا بطائرات
يبدو ان قياده الجيش لا تسيطر والا انها
او تعلم موقف وتعمل اذا التزم الجيش اذا
كانت هنالك حول لماذا لماذا انت تتهم
ضباطا في الجيش باختطاف قرار عبد الفتاح
البرهان
باختطاف قرار عبد الفتاح البرهان
الحركه الاسلاميه والضباط الاسلاميين في
الجيش البرهان قرار الجيش نفسه والجيش جيش
كله حركه الاسلاميه هنالك ضباط شرفاء
وهناك جنود هناك صغار ضباط ليس الجيش كله
في يد الحركه الاسلاميه ولكن بقرار الجيش
القوه الاحتياجاته قيادات العليا في الجيش
هذه القيادات منتميه وهنالك قيادات فاسده
تريد المحافظه على مصالحها تريد ان تستمر
في مواقعها لا تريد ان تسلم شركات الجيش
هنالك مصالح متضاربه كل هؤلاء يختطف
وا غرقوا في هذه المعرفه الان تحدث اليكم
الامريكيون اليوم وفي هذه الايام عموما
مجلس الامن القومي وغيرهم ما الذي دار في
الاتصالات مع الامريكيين
اهتمام
بيوقف العمليه وقت العمليات باعاده المسار
المدني في الديموقراطي باعاده العمليه
السياسيه حتى بامكانك بشكل جديد نحن لا
نرفض ان تعود ان يعود الشعب السوداني
اللي يتخذ قراره بيده نعتقد ان الامريكيين
تصورات حتى الان غير غير مكتمله نحن على
تواصل معهم
غير المكتمل كما تصفه الذي طرحه عليكم
الامريكيون
ليس لديهم مبادره واضحه كل ما
يريدونه الان التوصل لوقفه يطلق نار بعدها
التفكير في عمليه سياسيه حتى الان ليس
لديهم مقترح واضح هل عرضوا عليكم ارسال
مراقبين دوليين
حتى الان لم يعرضوا علينا ذلك مراقبين
دوليين دون التوصل
لاختي طبعا بعد التوصل اطلاق نار ولكن
انتم مستعدون لذلك هل انتم تقبلون
بمراقبين دوليين هل لكم اشتراطات معينه
لجهه جنسياتهم واليات عملهم
هذه مساله يمكن النقاش حول
لم ينظف النار النار مع من نتفاوض مع من
هذا سؤال كبير جدا مطروح اوامر امامنا
امام امام القوات المسلحه هل نوقف مع مع
ضباط مؤديين او مع علي كرسي او مع البرهان
نفسه هل البرهان يمتلك القرار الان هذه
اسئله لازم نصل فيها لاجابات قبل ان نجاوب
عليها هكذا اذا كانت هذه الاحزاب التي
تتهمها بالانقلاب موجوده على طاوله تفاوض
بما انها جزء من المشكله كما تقول لابد ان
تكون جزءا من الحل اليس كذلك الم تقبلوا
بها على طاوله تفاوض
لن نقبل في طاوله التفاوض مع الحركه
الاسلاميه مطلقه انت نقاتلهم وسنستمر في
قتالهم لن نقبل معهم لان هذه قوه تقبلونها
مع الجيش اولا تقبلونها مع الجيش اولا
للتوصل الى حل عسكري ومن ثم الانتقال الى
حل سياسي تجلسون مع البرهان
لا
من قبل ولا اي
حوار مع اشخاص مؤدبين الجيش فيه شرفاء
الجيش فيه ضباط لديهم مواقف معلنه لا يمكن
ابدا ان يخطف قرارهم يعودوا عبر التفاوض
الى
انتم تنحي البرهان اولا قبل البدء باي
مفاوضات
البرهان لا يملك شيء الان هو عمليا لا
يملك شيء
حضراتكم تؤيدون التفاوض مع تدعونا الى
تنحيته او الى تنحيه تنحيه قبل الدخول في
طاوله التفاوض مع الجيش
البرهان هو قائد العام للجيش هل يمتلك
القدره على وقت اطلاق النار هل يمتلك
القدره على التوقيع نيابه على الجيش هذا
تثبته الايام القادمه
البرهان لا يملك شيء
انتم الان عندما يتحدث اليكم الامريكيون
مثلا او اي قياده دوليه من الرباعيه دوليه
مثلا لن تقولوا لهم يعني مثل هذا الكلام
بالنتيجه في حتى لو اتهمتم البرهان بما
تتهمونه به هناك دعوات لوقف اطلاق النار
هناك تنسيق سيكون مع الجيش قائد الجيش
الان هو عبد الفتاح البرهان بالتالي انتم
ستتفاوضون معه على ماذا
نحن لم نوافق ولم تطرح علينا
الان نناقش هذا الامر داخليا ونناقشه مع
اطراف عديده داخليه البرهان حسب مجريات
الاحداث في الايام السابقه لا يملك قرار
الجيش ونحن نعلم من يوجه العمليات ومن
يديرها ونعلم
نعلم هنالك اكثر من 470 ضابط الان معنا
فموجودين من اسره في المعارك او سلمون
لانفسهم طوعا هؤلاء
كم عدد
الضبايه
انت تقول بانه 437 ضابط من الجيش السوداني
انشقوا وباتوا في صفوفكم
اسروا اسير عدد كبير منهم في المعارك نحن
عرضناهم في التلفزيون ميديا عبر
الفيديوهات وبعضهم سلم نفسه فورا واعلن
ذلك في فيديوهات منشوره في السوشيال ميديا
ضباط العسكريه ترتبهم معلومه سلموا انفسهم
ارتكازات الدعم السريع
واعلاف الجنود
وانفسهم هذا واقع موجود في الارض
يعني شاهدنا كثيرا من ذلك ولكن هذا تحت
قوه سلاح يعني
في اسرع انا لا انكر هنالك اسره في
المعاركوا اترك جدا من الضباط في في سرهم
الدعم السريع واعلن عنهم وعملهم معامله
حسنه وفي ما تقتضيه معامله الاسرى ولكن
هنالك ضباط ايضا سلموا نفسهم للدعم السريع
ورفضوا الحرب ورفضوا استمرار الحرب من
اراد منهم ان يذهب الى بيته من اراد ان
يخاطب يتصل باسرته نحن لا نمنعه كل من سلم
نفسه طوعا من حقي يعني ان يقلع يقلع
الكاكي ويسدم سلاحه ويذهب الى بيته نحن
ليس لدينا عداوه مع الجيش الجيش
جزء منكم استاذ يوسف
يا اخي يا هنالك مخالفه للتعليمات هنالك
انسحاب من المعارك
بعدم رغبه في القتال هنالك الغاء السلاح
شهدنا الكثير خلال العشره ايام الماضي
الجيش ليس لديه رغبه مقاتله الدعم السريع
الجيش لا ينظر للدعم السريع انه عدو حين
نقول الجيش نقول الجيش غير المؤدل حتى
الجنود ليس لديهم رغبه في مقاتله وليس حتى
لم نعبر في اي لحظه رغم انه الناطق الرسمي
للجيش وغيرهم يصفنا بالعدو ولكن نحن لم
نصف الجيش بالعدو لان الجيش السوداني
مؤسسه قوميه تم اختطافها من 89 تم تنفيذ
اجنده الحركه الاسلاميه بها نحن لا ننظر
للجيش انه عدو الجيش جيش جيش السودان وليس
جيش الكيزان وليس جيش البرهان الجيش جيش
السودانيين ابناء الشعب السوداني هم الذين
اقحمهم في هذه الحرب اذا نحن لا ننظر
الجيش انه عدو ولا حتى الان معركتنا ليست
مع الجيش السوداني ما هي دعوتكم لضباط
وجنود الجيش السوداني الان
الجيش السوداني نحن لا نهاجمهم ولا نسعى
لقتالهم نحن ارتكز في المواقع
الاستراتيجيه التي سيطرنا عليها مستكز في
المدن لحمايه نفسنا في الطرقات لحمايه
نفسنا لم نبادر بقتالهم وليس ولم نفكر
يوما من الايام طيله تاريخ الدعم السريع
طيله الازمه السياسيه التي مرت بها البلاد
في الفتره الماضيه لم نفكر ولم نخطط ابدا
لقتال الجيش السوداني فوجئنا بالحرب يوم
15 ابريل وجينا بها بالطائرات تضرب
معسكراتنا بيوتنا كل شيء في جنب القناصين
يستهدفون ارتكازاتنا كلها هذا حدث في يوم
وهذه لا تخص الشعب السوداني بل تخص تنظيم
محدد تنظيم استغل الجيش وحكم 30 سنه والان
يريد استخدام ذات الاداه للعوده الى
السلطه فالعقبه التي تقف امامهم هي الدعم
السريع واراد التخلص منها بعمليه خاصه
وفشل وتم فشل الانقلاب وتم فشل كل شيء
العمليه الوحيده التي نج
حت هي ما انجزوا علي
كرتي فهو ته
ريب ليس هنالك اي عمليه ناجحه اخرى ويجب
ان يفهم الجيش انه ليس لديه مصلحه
السوداني مصلحه في هكذا قتال
طيب الان اعود الى النقطه الاساسيه التي
كنا نتحدث عنها استاذ يوسف بشان عمر
البشير وقياداته هناك معلومات ترد اتاكد
الان بعدما وردت قبل قليل من انه عمر
البشير مع
قياديين اخرين كانوا اصلا في المستشفى
العسكري منذ فتره ولم يهرب من السجن او
يهربوا هل هذه معلوماتكم ايضا
يا اخي انا حسب المعلومات التي لدي انهم
كانوا داخل السجن هذه المعلومات انهم
كانوا داخل السجن هنالك
الراي انه كانوا في مستشفى الياه وغيرها
هذه معلومات غير مؤكده ولكن نحن لدينا
كل السجناء علي عثمان محمد طه نافع كل
السجناء الذين تم تهريبهم كانوا داخل
السجن تم تحري
حسن صالح وعبد الرحيم محمد حسين
هذه المعلومات التي المتوفره لدي انهم
كانوا
وهربوا من قبل
جماعتهم في الخارج
نعم اهرب باطلاق نار وهنالك عساكر اصيبوا
في هذه المتر هناك سجناء خليل تم اصيبوا
برصاص هل حاولت قوات الدعم السريع منع ذلك
هل كانت على درايه دامت سريع تم ابلاغه من
من من عساكر من عسكري في السجون بعد بعد
العمليه ان هنالك تمت عمليه كذا كذا
تحركت قوات الدعم السريع لقد كانت العمليه
قد تمت ونفذت ليس لدينا علم مسبق بالعمليه
وتوقيت هذا هذه عمليه دبرتها استخبارات
عسكريه لا نعلم
على مداخل ومخارج الخرطوم الا السجون
نحن لم نحرس السجود لان السجون المسؤوليه
الشرطه وحتى الان الشرطه ليست طرفا في في
صراع الدائره شرطه تلتزم الحياد الشرطه
تقوم بواجباته ومسؤولياتها نحن لا نحرس
السجون وليس لدينا اي مهام في السجون ولا
ولا ولا تتقاطع مهامه نقطه حساسه يعني
انتم يعني يعني الهدف من تحرككم كله انتم
تتهمون الجيش كله وتقاتلون الجيش كله بغض
النظر عن عما اذا كان منقسما او لا يعني
والان تعترف بالشرطه على حدا وتريد لها ان
تقوم بواجباتها
نغم الشرطه بازاله واجباتها الشرطه هنالك
مغارات كثيره تحرصها الشرطه لا تتعرض فيها
من قواتنا لاي اي اي تداوى ولا من الجيش
هناك ما زالت هنالك مغارات تقوم بحمايته
الشرطه غير هذا هنالك مواقع اخرى غير
السجون تحرسها الشرطه وماذا تمارس معها
الشرطه السودانيه شرطه قديمه وشرطه مدربه
شرطه موجوده تقوم بمهامها نحن لا نستطيع
او نعلن نفسنا بديلا للشرطه نحن نعلن
نفسنا لحمايه المدنيين من من اي اعتداء في
المناطق التي نسيطر عليها
قواتنا في تواجه حرب تؤمن مداخل المدن نحن
في حاله دفاعيه ولكن كيف تنقل بعد ذلك هم
من المفترض انهم توجهوا عندما هربوا من
السجن من المفترض انهم ذهبوا الى جهه امنه
اين كانت قوات الدعم السريع التي تقول
انها تسيطر على الكباري وعلى الطرقات وعلى
المداخل والمخارج
هذه القوه لم تعبر اي كبري من كباري من
الكباري الذين دبروا هذه العمليه خططوا
وهنالك في الجهات
دائما نحن الاستخبارات العسكريه في الجيش
دبرت لهذه العمليه لا ندري ليس لدينا
معلومات كامله عن كيف كيفيه اخراجهم لا
نعرف هل تم انزال جوي داخل السجن لا نعرف
ليس لدي معلومات حقيقيه ولكن هذه العمليه
بصوت عالم او هناك امكانيه لان يكون حدث
ذلك فعلا لانزال الجوي
نعم يمكن يمكن ان تنزل طائره عموديه
والاغلاق بهم هذه عمليه
بناء على معلومه غير مؤكده او بناء على
تحليل لا هذا تحليل هذا توقعات انا لا ليس
لدي معلومه عن كيفيه تنفيذ العمليه او
كيفيه اخلاقه من السجن لك هذا هذا مجرد
توقعات او احتمالات
هل انتم الان هل تعتبرون جزءا من واجبكم
الان البحث والتحري عنهم واعاده ضبطهم من
جديد
هنالك اشخاص اخرين متهمين في جرائم قتل
هنالك اشخاص اخرين اجرموا في حق الشعب
السوداني طوال 30 سنه نحن من مسؤوليتنا
وفي اطار حربنا
والذي يواجهون نبيها مسؤوليتنا وسنسعى
بغضهم سنسعى بكل ما يمكن ان يقبض القبض
عليهم
ديسم
بر هذا هذا اذا وصلت اياديكم الى عمر
البشير وعبد الرحمن عبد الرحيم محمد حسين
واحمد هارون المطلوبين للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه تسلمونهم
تسلمهم سلطه بعد تسجيل سلطه نحن الان لسنا
سلطه سياسيه تحكم البلد لسنا انقلاديين
الشعب السوداني يغرر مصيرهم هذا ليس قرار
يتخذها يتخذه الدعم السريع منفردا ولكن
سنحتفظ الى حين يغرب الشعب السوداني في
مصيرهم يعني تقول لست منقابيين لو كان نجح
تحرك اليوم الاول الم يكن حميتي ليقرا
البيان رقم واحد
اراد ان يقرا البيار رقم واحد لغراه في
اليوم الثاني هو الاول لا يوجد شيء اكثر
من انك تسيطر على القصر الجمهوري والاذاعه
والتلفزيون كل الانقلابات لم تفعلوا ذلك
لم تستطيعوا ان تفعلوا ذلك في الواقع اليس
كذلك لماذا يمنعني اذا كنا سلطه انقلابيه
ما الذي مش عارف مش واضح
على القصر وعلى القياده العامه هذا لم
يحصل
نحن الان موجودين في هذه المواقع
الجزئيه جزئيه ليس جز
ئيا هل هنالك القياده نحن الان نسيطر على
الجزء جزء كبير من مبادئها ومبانيها هنالك
فقط مبنى واحد فيه غناصه وبدروم وحراسات
وهذا بعد ان تفتح الاجواء وبعدها نستطيع
تامين وصول الصحفيين كله هو العالم كله
سياسي عنه باي مكان يعني القياده كبيره
فيها خمس مباني عن يعني لو اكيد مش راح
تعطينا احداثيات موقعك موقعكم ولكن يعني
على الاقل بعد التفاصيل لكي يصدق الشعب
السوداني ذلك او لا يا اخي نحن صورنا نحن
نقلنا نقلنا صور حيه من داخل مكتب كباشي
ومن داخل
ومن داخل مكتب
هاشم ياسر العطا كل هذه صور حيه نغنوا
وسائق تدين صحفيين كانوا يتلقون رواتب
نشرت ولم يتم غنى صور حيه من داخل القياده
العامه ولكن
الصور كانت من القصر اللي طلعتوها لا من
داخل
كباشي في القياده العامه
يا اخي
انا قلت لك ان هنالك بدرو هنالك مباني تحت
الارض في القياده العامه نحن نحن لا نتحدث
الان عن اين يوجد البرهان او اين هو لن
نتحدث عن هذا ولكن اذا البرهان موجود في
القياده العامه فليخرج ويخاطب الشعب من
امام مباني القياده العامه فليخرج فليخرج
فليرغي الكتاب حتى ان كان بصوره بالتلفون
هذا هذا هذا واقع موجود من اول يوم شو
معلوماتكم عن مكان تواجده اذا
نحن لا نفتح معلوماتنا نحن نتابع نحن نعمل
تتبع على لمواقعه اذا كنا
تحديد مكانه بالضبط لما لم انتظرنا لماذا
لا تقولون هذا الكلام ايضا لانفسكم اين
سيد حميدتي
طيب ظهرت هذه الصوره ولكن يعني ليس
باستطاعته على ما يبدو ان يخرج في خطاب من
مكان امن مستقر ذات هيئه سياديه
هو يتفقد قواته داخل القصر الجمهوري هذا
هذا هذا هدف لهذه الى هناك ويتفقد قواته
في اي موقع ويتحرك من موقع لموقع اخر بشكل
دائم ويقود قواتي ويوجهها ولا يدير
المعرفه في الخرطوم هل تعرض لمحاوله
اغتيال
لم يحدث لم يحدث
لا
لا بشكل مباشر ولا بشكل غير مباشر بمعنى
انه تعرض لقصف مثلا او مثلا لا لم يتعرض
لاي محاوله اغتيال طيله الايام الماضيه
قياداته المقربه ايضا
جميع قيادات الدعم السريع المقربه سواء
كانت مدنيه وعسكريه بسلام وبامان
ماذا عن الدور الذي يقوم به شقيقه الان
شقيقه قوات الدعم السريع نحن نعلم ذلك
نسال
مهام عملياتيه في قياده هذه المعركه
نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع من
الخرطوم تحياتي اليك ونستمع الان الى
اعلان القيادي احمد هارون في القيادي في
نظام الرئيس السابق عن خروج قيادات عديده
من النظام السابق من السجن
بما في ذلك حبسنا كره هائل لديها طلبا
لرضا سياسيه واخرى اقليميه ودوليه ثبت
الان انها العدو الاول للشعب السوداني
وللسلطه القائمه ولقواته المسلحه فهي من
تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان
ونفرغ تماما ما بين القائمين على تلك
السلطه ومؤسسات الدوله الوطنيه وفي
مقدمتها قواتنا المسلحه التي تقاتل بشرف
وبشجاعه وبساله كالعدي بها دوما وندعو كل
جماهير الشعبنا
وعضويتنا لمزيد من الالتفاف حولها
ومساندتها واستراح المبادره التي تسند
دورها الوطني الذي تقوم به الان
جماهير سعدنا الوفيه ضلنا كقيادات للثوره
الانقاذ الوطني بمحبسنا
تحت تقاطع نيران المعرفه الدائره الان
لمده تسعه ايام
نتشارك وبقيه نزلاء السين وسجانيه تلك
الظروف الامنيه الاستثنائيه
وانعدام مقومات الحياه من انقطاع تام
للمياه والكهرباء والطعام والرعايه الصحيه
حتى للجرحى من جراء تساقط النيران وسط قوه
السجون والنزلاء والتي توفى من جرائها
العديد منهم وجرح
اخر
ومنفجار الاوضاع داخل السجن بخروج كل
النزلاء يوم الاحد 23 ابريل 2023 من السجن
عنوه
حتى خلى تماما من نزلائه وصيانه فيما عدا
قله لا تتجاوز العشره
من قاده وضباه وافراد وبناء على طلب القوه
المتبقيه من قوه السجون تحركنا لموقع اخر
خارج
حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه على امل ان تتحصل سلطات السجون على
امر القضاء بالافراد عنا حسب افادتها خلال
ذلك اليوم لنواجه مع جماهير شعبنا لا تزور
فيه وتحدياته والقيام معه بذات الواجبات
الوطنيه فلم تعد هناك سيون قائمه ولا مقار
لمباشره اجهزه ووكالات انفاذ القانون
لمهامها
وهكذا في الانقياده ضريبتها والتزاماتها
ونفخر ونحمد الله كثيرا على تشربنا تماما
لقيم موروثات شعبنا التي يعبر عنها بالمثل
السمعه ولا طوله العمر
واذا عدم صدور الامر القضائي المستحق
قانونا لاسباب غير قانونيه
عنها لاحقا وفي ظل تسارع وتتابع الاحداث
وازدياد حته الاشتباكات وتعاظم النذر
والمخاطر من حولنا وفي ظل انشغال السلطات
الاخرى بمهامها في اداره المعركه الوطنيه
الان القائمه فقد اتخذنا قرارا الخاص بنا
بان نتحمل المسؤوليتنا في حمايه انفسنا
بانفسنا وجاهزون للوصول امام السلطه
القضائيه متى ما تمكنت من القيام بمهامها
هي واجهزه هي واجهزتها المسانده لها ثقه
منا في سلامه موقفنا القانوني
ولنتقاسم مع شعبنا ادوارهم بطوليه
في الصبر والثبات والدفاع عن كيان دولته
من الاختطاف تحيه والتقدير والنصر لشعبنا
ولقواته المسلحه وهم يقاتلون في معركه
الكرامه الوطنيه
وندعو
منسوبي الدعم السريع المنحل
للانخراط مع اخوتهم في القوات المسلحه
وترك الالتزام تجاه قيادتهما الحاليه التي
ثبت انها تقودهم لمشروع شخصي واسري فقط
تقبل الله الشهداء
وشاف الجرحى ورد المفقودين وواسل متضررين
والمتاثرين وما مصر الا صبر ساعه ينصره
الله فلا غالب لكم والله قالب على امره
احمد محمد هارون عن المعتقلين من قيادات
الانقاذ بسيم كوبر بتاريخ 25 ابريل
[موسيقى]
لنا يعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
معنا في الاستوديو مجددا لنا هل لدينا
معلومات مؤكده عن القيادات التي
يعني اخرجت او هربت او من السجن وعن تلك
التي كانت اصلا في المستشفى
نعم طاهر طبعا البشير كان يتردد في مستشفى
السلاح الطبي في ام درمان بالعاصمه
الخرطوم طبعا في الاونه الاخيره وكانت
دائما ما تقدم طلبات الى المحكمه بانه
مريض لذلك هو كان يتنقل ما بين السجن
والمستشفى كذلك نائبه الاسبق بكري حسن
صالح كذلك هناك قيادات اخرى مثل يوسف عبد
الفتاح الطيب الخنجر ايضا من القيادات
التي كانت في المستشفى بالتالي هم كانوا
موجودين في المستشفى قبل اكثر من شهر بحسب
المعلومات التي تحصلنا عليها هناك قيادات
اخرى كانت موجوده في السجن مثل نافعه
لنافع عوض الجاز
كمال عبد المعروف
نعم علي عثمان محمد طه الذي كان طبعا نائب
البشير يعني الاسبق الفاتح عز الدين
ابراهيم السنوسي علي الحاج كثير من
القيادات التي كانت متهمه بتقويض نظام
بتقويض النظام الدستوري عام 89 هي تحا في
هذه التهمه وطبعا هذه الجلسات لم تستمر
ودائما ما يتم تغيير القضاه لذلك هم دائما
في حاله
تمديد
للمحاكمه في هذه الدول جميعهم هؤلاء كانوا
مسجونين على ذمه تحقيق في هذه القضايا ليس
لدينا يعني مدانون بعد لم يكن لدينا
مدانون بقضايا كامله ولكن هناك مطلوبون
منهم للجنائيه الدوليه وهذا موضع خطر جدا
بالنسبه الى الثلاثه الاساسيين عمر البشير
عبد الرحيم محمد حسين واحمد هارون الذي
استمعنا الى تسجيله للتو كيف سيكون الموقف
باعتقاده طبعا كانت يعني المحكمه الجنائيه
ترسل كثير من المندوبين الى السودان وكان
قضاه المحكمه الجنائيه ايضا حضروا الى
السودان مشددين على ضروره تسليم هذه
القيادات ولكن لم تكن هناك استجابه حتى
حينما كانت حكومه الفتره الانتقاليه
موجوده حكومه حمدوك كانت هناك انبات تتحدث
عن استعداد للتعاون ولكن لم يتم التسليم
لان موضوع التسليم ايضا كان يرفضه الجيش
بان يسلم ضابط سابق من الجيش السوداني الى
المحكمه الجنائيه بالتالي هذا الامر لا
يشكل من وجهه نظر الخطوره لان السودان لم
يسلم اي مطلوب كان هناك مطلوب هو الذي قرر
ان يذهب الى المحكمه الجنائيه علي كوشيب
ولكن بقيه القيادات اصلا التي هي مطلوبه
لم تطلب ان تذهب ولم تقم الدوله سواء كان
في حكومه حمدوك او حتى المكون العسكري
بتسليمها طيب استمعنا الى مباركه احمد
هارون لتحرك الجيش ولحربه على قوات الدعم
السريع الى ما هنالك واستمعنا الى اتهامات
يوسف عزت قبل قليل مستشار السيد حميدتي
للجيش انا لا اريد ان اتحدث عن يعني
انتماءات في الجيش ولكن اريد ان اسال عن
الواقع اللي بالفتره الاخيره صار عندما
يعني غابه المشاهد عن السودان قليلا قبل
انفجار الوضع مجددا
تصريحات المحسوبين على التيار الاسلامي او
الحركه الاسلاميه عموما اين كانت من
المشهد السياسي في البلاد من الاتفاق
الاطاري ومالاته كانت رافضه للاتفاق
الاطاري بصوره معلنه وكانت تطلق في كثير
من الاحيان تهديدات وهذا الامر كان ايضا
يسبب يعني رد من الجانب الاخر خاصه من
جانب الحريه والتغيير التي كانت تتحدث بان
فنون النظام هم من يسعون الى افشال
العمليه السياسيه كانوا دائما ما يقومون
بتسيير بعض الاحتجاجات خاصه امام مقر
المبعوث الاممي فولكربرس ولكن يعني كان
هذا الرفض متوقعهم دائما ما يقومون برفض
اي عمليه سياسيه لا تشملهم وحتى اللحظه لم
يتم اي اجماع من اي قوى سياسيه بانهم
يرغبون بان يكون المؤتمر الوطني جزءا منها
فهذا الامر كان متوقع ولكن ان يكون لهم يد
فيما يحدث هذا هو ما يستحق كثير من البحث
والمعلومات تماما ومن هنا كان الهجوم
الكبير قبل قليل من يوسف عزت على علي كرتي
الذي ذكره مرارا في حديثه شكرا جزيلا
يعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
دكتور محمد زياد مستشار المركز المصري
للفكر ودراسات الاستراتيجيه من القاهره
مجددا العلك استمعت معنا الى ما الى
الحوار مع يوسف عزت مستشار محمد حمدان
دقله
ماذا يقول لك يعني كل كلامه حول المرحله
كان عسكريا او سياسيا
دعني في البدايه يعني اسجل تقديري لحوارك
الذي اجريته معه فانت طرحت كافه الاسئله
التي يمكن ان تطرح ولم تترك للمحللين من
امثالي نقطه للبحث والحديث فيها يعني انت
دفعت الرجل لن يتحدث بوضوح
تحدث عن امور ورد عليها يعني عندما يقول
انهم يتحكمون في كل الطرق في مدينه
الخرطوم وفي المرتكزات الرئيسيه وسالت اذا
كنت تتحكمون اين ذهبوا هو الهدف الرئيسي
له وانا في اعتقادي قبل حديثي هذا وقبل
هروب هذه الشخصيات كيف كان الواقع العسكري
الواقع العسكري كان لصالح الجيش وليس
لصالح قوات الدعم السريع والدليل على ذلك
محاولتها استخدام قوات اخرى من دارفور
والتي ضرب الجيش المسار الذي يمكن ان
تدفعه حتى لا تصل تلك القوات الى العاصمه
التي تعاني من ضعف فيها قوات دعم سريع
تمركز القوات في الاحياء السكنيه
لانها فشلت في المواجهه المباشره وتريد
تحديد قوات الجيش في مواجهتها بحس يعجز
اما ان يضرب المدنيين واما ان يتركها
تتحرك كما تريد بمعنى ذلك ان القوات الدعم
السريه تتحكم حسب كلامه لكنها تركتهم انا
في اعتقادي ان قوات الدعم السرير ارادت ان
تخلط الاوراق وان تزيد من اتهاماتها للجيش
بانه تابع للنظام السابق
واطلاق سراح هؤلاء الافراد كان عمليه خلطه
اوراق لانه يدخل طرف تبقى هناك قضيه اخرى
وهناك محاوله لوسم الجيش انه ما يجري ليست
ردا على محاوله الدعم السريع السيطره على
الاوضاع ولكن هو محاوله من
النظام السابق ده الى العمل السياسي في
السودان في اعتقادي ايضا انه الدعم السريع
اطلاق النار الحالي انت كشفت من اسئلتك عن
موضوع مهم اخر انهم يرفضون جهود الوساطه
طالما البرهان قائم وهذا مؤشر على ان
الدعم السريع يدرك ان اي تفاوض سوف يعني
في النهايه انسحاب الجيش الى سكناته
والعوده الحياه المدنيه تمام وبالتالي
التفاوض
دكتور اعذرني يعني اسف على المقاطعه ولكن
لابد ان انتقل الى زميلي ليستلم الساعه
الثانيه من التغطيه شكرا جزيلا لوجودك
معنا الدكتور محمد زياد مستشار المركز
المصري للفكر ودراسات الاستراتيجيه من
القاهره تحياتي اليك على وجودك معنا في
هذه التغطيه شكرا لبقيه ضيوفنا ومراسلينا
وصحفينا والى صهيب شراير معه بقيه التغطيه
اليك لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات